大家好 我哲哲
哇 今天周末大家看到我
我犧牲我的重訓時間
今天先來 跟大家直播
告訴大家
禮拜一台灣股市會不會直接崩1000點
台子期跌了1000多點啊
好多人問我
美國股市也沒有什麼漲跌
怎麼會這樣子才高興一天
哲哲 元大台灣50台積電展停板
怎麼辦 你昨天紅遍大街小巷
脆 哇
臉書通通都是你的新聞
說你一億
買台灣50
馬上賺1000萬
可是
禮拜一要跌1000點怎麼辦
那會不會展真的 展假的
禮拜五是不是展真的
禮拜一會不會是跌真的
禮拜五是展真的
禮拜一是不是
怎樣
這一次來大的
我們來跟大家講三個大重點
亞馬遜現金流為富房額大漲
這是好事還是好壞事
融資積增100億閃毀了
不太妙
融資積增100多億
韓國會再疊下去會不會再救市
這三大重點
今天週末我來跟大家加班
到我是摩托頭顧的投資長
郭忠文醫師
接下來我們交給主播
立立不在是不是
投資長還有我小韓
還有妳小韓 還有我金金
你們這兩個有什麼用
好啦開玩笑的啦
金金你也在是不是
好啦謝謝你
金金那個不顧家庭來幫我們加班
對不起
對不起你家人
沒有啦開玩笑啦
來啦
我們來看一下大家
互動一下
你們覺得禮拜一會不會展會點
我跟大家講
我們那天不是有投票嗎
百分之五三的人還有錢嗎
還有現金啊
百分之四十七的沒有錢
所以百分之五三的人
你現在就很開心
47%的人就要講
你股票如果有些跌
沒有跌很深的
有些股票如果沒有跌很深的
沒有跌超過30%的
你要換股
你要來找我
好不好
一一不見了
沒辦法啦
來
有戴手錶
特別帥
今天手錶不太一樣
好不好
OK嗎
來
今天有認證了
美國少年股神
被投阿爾街狙殺
這是個故事吧
就是股神
人家槓桿用四倍啊
不論是不是股神
都是一樣
不要用槓桿
你就贏了那些股神了
好不好
酬帝有沒有錢
租公
有沒有宰一次
宰一次
租公不能宰
租公
先拿來宰
把錢裡面掏出來
責安基金要二度進場了沒
你當我家開銀行
什麼事
禮拜一一定跌
現在問題來了
你先想我的問題
今天如果沒有禮拜五
崩盤
先這樣講
今天禮拜六
台灣股市如果
就是台紫期嘛
夜盤
沒有跌1000點
我請問你
這個週末你看到台積電暫停
你看到跌很深的國劇暫停
是不是
你看到2408南亞科暫停
你看到829的群年
假設今天
暫停後
禮拜五暫停
你很後悔
你沒有跟著我的責攬基金
有人是這樣稱讚
我不敢
我不小心這樣說啦
你不敢跟著我一億台幣去追隨他
禮拜五的時候你看到的時候
你是很可惜的
沒有錯吧
禮拜五看到的時候你是很可惜的
禮拜六大跌了
你看到這些暫停你就不理他了
我這件事
禮拜五的時候你們明明一明一堆人
想要進場買股票買不到
結果今天禮拜一可能台灣股市開低點點
你又不買
你真的是
变来变去耶
如果谈感情就是渣男的
你知道吗
不要这么变来变去
各位投资朋友
好不好
奇怪
礼拜五暂停你们都想买
你们挂着
哇一千多张
国具两万多张
是不是两万三千多张
暂停满买不到
礼拜一让你买到不好吗
春天制作所礼拜五是暂停几%
禮拜五是涨什麼
涨15%
要免錢的直接下載這個
Investing打看
直接用這個
還有金石數據不錯
這些東西都不錯
這大家教大家
好不好
海力是禮拜五還涨快30%
29%跟26%
好不好
這跟大家講
所以你要去相信我講的話
可是我覺得一個人有點乾
我突然覺得我需要主持人
你知道嗎
我需要主持人
可是好像没有画面
就是尴尬
那没有关系
我先请一下
那个
今天女生有谁
金金
金金你取代那个1
好不好
好的
这我们公司就是一定要有叠字
金金11233
没有
33没有来
因为33来迟
1122也没有
2还在生
金金跟莉莉
好不好
那我们来看一下
我们先来简讯图
帮我念一下
国际的简讯
好的
7月31号礼拜五简讯
恭喜2327国具
股价一开盘就涨停锁死
股价腰斩危机暂时解除
我持续看好它
手上持股抱好抱牢
我命中
要喝水
因为一个人讲话
有时候会不顺
要喝个水
来
三席会影响
三席一定会影响
台湾股市今年没有利空
接下来都是利多
Watch me
小岸
Watch me你听不懂意思
看我
转过来再次我们再次
再次小岸
再次
Watch me
對 不錯
我們先喊個口號
今天先喊口號
來 今天有誰
今天沒人啊
好不好
來來 我們一起喊一下
團結
信心
紀律
策略
勝利
不錯
那依依跟那個四雅
你們可以
莉莉可以休息了
好不好
這三個也不錯
中氣十足
我覺得不錯
我知道為什麼
今天這三個不錯了
小韓嘛對不對
是
有家庭嘛
然後金姬嘛
也有家庭嘛
有兩個兒子
兩個兒子
Kidder嘛
也兩個兒子嘛
兩個兒子
原來喔
比較認好認怨啦
跑不掉啊
難怪今天口...你們覺得今天比較好
開玩笑的啦
我對他們都不錯啦
有些人住比較遠
像比如四小住比較遠
還有莉莉也住比較遠
所以那個...
今天三個人而已
口號比昨天還厲害
所以真的住比較遠
什麼邪教
哎呀
你們不知道我用心良苦
你說是邪教
彥博人你說我們是邪教
那你也變成邪教的一員啦
對不對
OK
沒有蠟筆小心頭套
欸
昨天喔 我跟你講
我後來也知道我心裡有些時候
我跟家瑋老師還算熟
人家要做多做空
我不以置評
但我沒有要批評人家
哎唷 我戴什麼小心頭套
我想起來
之前好像
有個人要批評他
那個不關我的事情
我們要參與他
我做多就做多
我們要參與人家的恩怨
好不好
OK嗎
談談談句不錯
好,來
先跟大家講
沒想到跟到直播
你看看今天直播人數
今天直播人數四千多人
不錯耶
你們也不錯
蠻閒的
還是說
不是閒的
不久看我節目
比看一般的直播好玩
對不對
來,我跟大家講結論的
watch me,watch me
結論就是
但是今年就是5萬點
好不好
今年就是5萬點
我認為美國到伊蘭
但是伊蘭不認同美國人
但我覺得川普到最後
還是會和談
這第一個
這談比較久
第二個
我說既然到5萬點
明年6萬點
明年6萬點我大概賺5000萬
我會明年6萬點以上才出
才出喔
有可能不出
包軍第三台救護車
下一台救護車
差不多五六百萬
你去問他囉
就差不多了
好不好
之前比較便宜一點的
我們一台救護車
都可以去買凱宴
買居有益的
但我買這個比較開心
到時候再捐出來
好不好
這個跟大家講
所以五萬點拉回都做多
不要想那麼多
昨天韓國股市很好玩的
所以韓國股市如果沒有看錯的話
好像
好像那個
外資買了2000億
我看那數字很誇張
六兆還八兆
然後賞戶是賣的
除非韓國是賣的
真的很不團結
所以你看我們台灣的賞戶多團結
因為台灣的賞戶比較不賭
你本來這一波只要不賭的人
都不用怕
好不好
OK
美債要爆炸
因為美債錢滾錢越來越爆
所以不要買美債了
好不好
美債留我受傷
上一次沒有跟到
只剩36000
這次要更好
沒有錯
今天肯定50000點
不要說肯定
我說很有高機率
好不好
OK嗎
今天怎麼上班
我跟大家講
因為第一個
因為我是能來風
最近我很紅
我就來上班
好吧
但本來就很紅了
只是最近已經
就點閱率多個一二十萬
那還是來一下好不好
OK
太陽 右墊跟腎高也都暫停
環球晶準備噴出
四小有在嗎對不對
那金金有在嗎對不對
在
請大家幫我查一下太陽 右墊跟腎高
好不好
對啊 太陽 右墊跟腎高
暫停環球晶在幹什麼
是不是
環球晶盤中一度拉扯
最後終於暫停
因為大家覺得環球技術財報不好看
我才不在乎它
我就跟大家講一件事情
記憶體也好
世界先進好
台積電都需要先進製成
你們現在看的是
我以前的超級循環
國具跟AB5宅版一樣
跟記憶體一樣
你們都是老梗了
老題材了
國具1220元
很難突破
800元有機會
滿高的
所以你賺到60%有機會
而且你來找我
我還可以幫你做價差
有國具的我來救你們
我告訴你們
昨天的雄友這一段
國具我叫他攢就攢
沒有錯吧
我從300元那邊附近做
我叫他攢就攢
我叫
我看歪他
他不敢攢
然後呢
我叫他攢
馬上攢
我那時候
每次都說我批評
搖直金魔
沒有
我跟他一起
站在同一個陣線
我還前天跟他講
你看他有沒有看我節目
你們自己去猜嗎
看我節目的人正常
那麼多人看我
體驗率動輒二三十萬
我說我要買國具
我說我支持姚子金母
結果他是說裡面
主動型ETF裡面
買國具的
你買得多漂亮
結果昨天聽說姚子金母
只買什麼
買台紙棋
那他怎麼辦
我不管他
我不是在拚他
因為很多股票都暫停
好不好
我要拼了
我講話
OK
環球金卡高點
我們環球金有500多元買的
好不好
來
背中元件isback
我不用isback來說
我會說至少沒有破底
好不好
美債
哲哲你可以叫他漲嗎
不好意思
我叫不動川普
所以美債也沒辦法
哲哲覺得國際會回千元嗎
有機會
因為如果台灣股市破6萬點
為什麼國際不能回千元
那種什麼事
可是我跟你講你有台積電的人
你真的要換股票
因為台
就像我講的
這講我一個理論
台積電離錢高這麼近
可是台灣股市不會很快就
台股跟台積電是一步一趨的
台股不會很快
就突破四萬八
既然台灣股市不會突破四萬八
那台積電要創新高也很難
可是台積電離創新高距離很近
大概這一段到這一段
懂嗎
那這一段漲幅不多
你為什麼不把台積電換成國具
換成環球晶
換成群年之類的呢
真的很多人受傷沒有關係
好不好
散戶也先回來
你看台灣散戶
我們看一下融資預額
你看我還是有做圖表
好不好
來
融資預額有沒有看到
從那個
那個最高點6300
有沒有
6300億有沒有看到
6300億3億的那個融資預額有沒有看到好一路一路一路怎麼樣殺到4938億這個總共大家殺到多少
1400億
今天增加135億
我覺得還好
因為我們減了1400億嘛
所以我覺得這很棒
為什麼這很棒
因為我們減了1400億
我們今天談了增加135億
才攢3000點
那換句話說
我們有可能不用增加到800億
就突破到48000
我們減1400億
增加800億
就可以突破48000甚至50000點
所以我們比前一
我們在突破
我們來到50000點的時候
比之前的48000點
等容資源大概減少600億
這樣好不好
當然好啊
當然好啊好不好
你們喜歡我稍微團結
轉風賣少一點
還是太專業
我怕你們這還不算專業
我們繼續專業下去喔
好不好
我要專業也可以啊
來
亞馬遜啦
我先講亞馬遜啦
他沒有很遜
昨天公布財報嘛
15.3%
他最好玩的地方是什麼你看
他這邊大漲對不對
亞馬遜對不對
亞馬遜很多人
之前亞馬遜當然不看好他
說什麼現金流為負啊
你看他自由現金流為負
去年同期是振180而已
現在已經轉成-76億
你們記得我前幾天還在討論
華爾街在討論
現金流量為負
自由現金流量為負
那這代表什麼
我要解釋什麼
自由現金流量
你去這個現金
去減掉這個資本支出
來這邊有講過
自由現金流為負
就是營業現金減掉資本支出
等於什麼
自由現金流是負的
這哪家公司
特斯拉那時候公佈
跟Alphabets
我這個圖表給大家看過嗎
叫Google
Google跟特斯拉公佈後
都大跌
為什麼
聽什麼
亞馬遜
公佈自由現金的量為負以後
反而轉
代表是什麼
之前是假議題
我就說我找理由跌而已
我找理由跌而已
你知道嗎
昨天台達電的法說怎麼說
AI用過回不去了
真的回不去了啦
你們自己每個人講你們AI
來來來
我就是舉手表決一下
你們用AI以後
你們自己投票表決
有NINI的人投票
AI程式啦
就GIMA,CHERGPT
Cloud都可以
用AI的人
你用了以後
是使用時間越來越多
還是使用時間越來越少
越來越多就一直增加
舉手表決
你們先問一問
知道嘛
你知道Bobby特叫什麼
生活投資法
他買可口可樂
他可口可樂買這股票
買幾千億以上
不只幾千億有財幣的話
為什麼
因為他每天要喝可口可樂
覺得很好喝
你今天你要買AI
你要知道有沒有人在用AI
你不知道沒關係
今天去投去問一下
用AI的人是越來越多
先問兩個問題
所以是假的沒關係
先問這個問題好了
你用AI的時間越多越少
好不好
沒關係 答案就可以投票了
我需要Token 投資多了
沒關係 這個我們
這個也叫生存整理論啦
那個我們要投票比較實在好不好
老師好用心去禮拜六開直播
不只我們
我們我的分析師都很用心好不好
來 用過就不缺
免費也算 也算 沒關係 沒關係
投票
有開嗎
如果視野不能開
你那個KID要幫我開
來
這跟大家講
謝謝周六開的節目
我都用AI做幹片跟廢圖
不錯啊 這很好玩啊 好不好
我愛你
你愛我的身體是不是
我很難過
你們可不可以多一點
愛我身體喔
到底如果一個人給我選擇
他是愛我身體
我比較開心
還是愛我的錢
我很難選擇耶
沒有啦
你該愛我頭腦嘛各位
好啦
這個是誰
Love to AI
好啦好啦
你們要表白都可以啦
以後從捐捐消防車變捐算力
GD老師很認真
對 一定要認真
來來
投票人還沒有
市場沒在現場是不是
沒關係 要Key 幫我開
這還要加嗎
每次看到貓咪跳舞影片
對啊 大家很喜歡看貓咪跳舞
AI本來就有未來
我本來以為貓咪那種跳舞很假
大家很喜歡 發現大家很喜歡
我本來以為
我本來以為那種AI的影片很假的
會沒有人看
大家都看
可是當隨著AI越來越真的時候
當你已經分不清真假的時候
其實你花時間越來越久
你只要眼珠在那邊
那個營收就一定會出來
你只要花時間越來越多
那個一定會出來
營收會出來
不要怕那四門子出
那都假的好不好
OK
第一次來好笑
來
你看
你自己看
使用AI
開始使用的時間是越多越少
96%的人是越多
5%的人你要注意一下
我講實話我比較機車
你要被社會淘汰了
用了AI你還不知道AI好用
我是說真的
除非你是70歲以上
算了我不為過
老媽媽本來就不太會用
如果用了AI時間
用了以後你覺得不好用
你用了5%
你很快被淘汰
你相信我
我這樣講話很討厭
你久了就知道我說是對的
好不好
來
你要all in 政二
那你要all in 政二就要政二
好不好
那不是我想法好不好
我欠人看直播
來
AI製作電影好像好逼真對啊
所以以後誰會看
所以我忘記跟你講
有一些職業
拜託你們現在18歲年輕的
或你家裡有小孩的
18歲要選擇工作
第一個
那個
演員不要選了好不好
很辛苦
台灣演員現在就很辛苦
台灣現在演員
你一紅要去大陸發展
不然市場不大
是不是
這是事實啊
好不好
台灣演員
歌手我還不確定
因為我現在看不到那個
好像是叫Sumo是不是
那個最近好像還被告侵權
就是AI的那個音樂
那個演員
演員要注意一下
不只是你帥不帥
AI的人比你更帥
而且一輩子
都是停留在25到30歲
都可以這樣做
演員
駕駛
還有客服
那特斯拉的那個老闆
馬斯克說醫生也不需要了
沒有沒有醫生絕對需要
雖然有時候我說AI可以幫我做很多事
所以醫生太煩了
醫生不會在診間回答我很多問題
所以你可以問很多
診間後或在看診之前
你可以先準備問AI你什麼病
拍個照 問AI什麼病
問清楚會問
好 所以我講駕駛員
不是駕駛員 不是飛機的我不確定
講是一般的計程車的
我想確定的 你們要注意
就真的會被取代 很多人被取代
還有翻譯的 做翻譯的
語言的 相關的
真的不要
可以讀這個戲
但你不要覺得這個戲可以賺錢
還有客服人員
好不好
這我跟大家講
趕快轉行
好不好
不然就買AI股
不然摸也可以
摸我們現在
研究人員
還有那個業務人員還缺
很多人年薪千萬
我是說真的
買人就不管了
好不好
OK
這我愛你
Philip
你們可以
你們多一點
你們是直的變彎的
你可以多一點男女生嗎
沒有啦
開玩笑
因為每天已經小韓已經都暗示我了
OK
五千多人看直播
Guardian
來
所以老師說我買0050沒GG
我們很熟啦
他們都喜歡吃虎豆腐
虎扯啊
因為我很熟
我跟我說我就不喜歡買槓桿
但我不是要批評人家啦
好不好
92%
可是不管啊 92%你看
使用AI的人92%越來越多
所以這個我跟你講
所以用AI越來越回不去了
好不好
只能說我們科系的大學生
然後我們當分析師
有些人也不一定是那個科系
那也沒有一定
重點是你努力努力
對股票市場有沒有興趣
好不好
如果破底還
破底還什麼表
我一下子
我以為破底還能買什麼表
沒有
破底還能買
如果破底
我跟你講一件事好不好
破底都要買
我做過研究
如果是台灣50對不對
如果是台灣50
什麼時間買都對
這怎麼這樣講
來
如果他回到最後是回到5萬點
就這麼簡單的邏輯
最後到10萬點
請問你我要4萬3買還是4萬買
你有下班
而且上班族的
你下班都沒時間了
有時間上
嘿嘿嘿
小安
我都已經畫10個圈
你兩位轉過來實在是很混
我突然想起1.1了
好不好
小安下個禮拜你可以不用來上班了
欸
昨天不是說你不用來上班嗎
欸是沒錯
喔啊就是聽到我這
我太愛你了沒辦法
什麼
我太愛你也沒辦法
可以不要這樣子嗎
好不好
謝謝
來
來 我們是43000
都已經43000了
5萬點
如果4年後
4年後10萬點後
然後現在43000
4萬要幹嘛
你們不投資
不行好不好
OK嗎
要投資好不好
愛你們
來
對對我們要講一些重要的
所以
好啦為什麼台灣股市跌
還是講一個原因
因為台灣股市漲太多了
漲怎麼樣多你們自己看喔
我們不要說哪地賽啦
哪地賽不好
我是很專業的
好不好
就是有時候
團結
那是節目效果
看起來那麼傻嘛
有嗎
沒有吧
你們看一下
看那個
我剛才講哪邊
Key人都在混喔
我剛才講什麼
對對為什麼
來看議價
來主要ETF
你們看台灣50
為什麼
你今天是喔
有沒有看到
我看到台灣50展停板就覺得很扯
我們看到台灣50對不對
是那一天有沒有展停板
2025年4月的時候好像已經展停板了
對 這2025年4月
這一次比較扯啦
因為那個有
你知道 我跟你講就是
我這次賺一天賺一千塊很扯
因為有人算過機率
因為基本上台灣50不太會展停板
台灣50展停板
你要台積店紅還展停板
我買了以後隔一天就展停板
這幾年我沒有記錯的話
就是今年跟去年的四月的時候
因為股災跟現在很像
然後展停板
那一次我也是抓得很準
那一次我也抓得很準
然後那一次抓得非常準
然後我要告訴大家
兩天就一買就可以展聽版
機率是幾十萬分之一
懂不懂
等於就是重樂透的感覺
重大樂透但機率更低
所以你去打聽一下
這買一億然後買低點多厲害
好 我要講這東西來
我跟你講
順便講到去年的時候
去年那不是有股災嗎
那我們看一下
這邊
去年
七月的時候股災
這邊的骨折
你看他這一天是不是展停板
這一天是展停板
因為跌很深嘛
從2萬2 2萬3有沒有看到
從這邊有沒有
然後一路跌
這跌很多
跌大概6000點
好這邊這一根是展停板
我們放大
我們這一根是展停板
這一根是展停板
隔天有沒有看到
再看一下喔
這一根的展停板
注意一下
隔天有下影線
收在這邊
收這邊有沒有看到
隔壁下影線代表什麼意思
就是我在崩盤的時候
來喔 今天的走勢
來自我獨家的喔
這就是指責股市30年的好處
這兩次喔
這一天跟上次一樣是台積電
暫停板 我沒記錯
台灣50暫停板
這一天
在4月9號的下個交易日
因為跌很深嘛
那時候有沒有印象 拜託留言
指責說這個時候
不要左側加益
因為那時候關稅很恐怖要右側交易右側交易就是確定反彈再去追而且會反彈超過1000點有印象舉手我說這邊開始做多你看這邊開始做多等於17000的隔天
大概19000開始做多
好
有印象舉手
大家留言說有
我指的也是在這一天
這兩天買台灣50的
厲害吧
好
有沒有印象
小黃有沒有印象
有
有喔
所以你看19000這附近
後來就漲到變成39000了
變成48000了
對不對
好
這不是重點
重點是看這一根
看一次喔
這一根很重要
這邊收盤架
這邊收盤架這邊
對過去再有一次
它下面有下影線
代表隔一天
暫停板技巧
暫停板隔一天
有些人不相信會暫停
它今天隔日從
比如我國具我今天買到
我明天就想要賣掉
或者我怕我賣壓
或者我是前天買的
我是禮拜四買的
所以它暫停完以後
隔天有下引線
可是最後呢
还是拉起来
那时候
它暂停完以后
有下引线
暂停完以后
台湾股市暂停
台积电暂停
然后台湾50暂停
隔天还是有下引线
因为大家不相信
就跟现在韩国股市一样
韩国股市到今天
到礼拜五的时候
散户是卖的
所以礼拜五
有可能会先杀下去
原本就要杀
因为签点
最后
我认为
当然预测
我认为会跌到
有机会
我不能说一定
有机会会跌个
会少跌个什么
跌到300点以内
300点以内
甚至翻红
我先跟大家讲
我不敢说100%
这个机率也不能说90%太高
我认为70%
明天跌的幅度会在-300点以内
甚至有机会
翻紅
記起來我說的
好不好
為什麼
因為最重要的
亞馬遜的財報
是自由現金流量是負的
之前大家怕自由現金流量為負的
AI是怕什麼
現在不太小
不理會這件事情
好不好
我想那台語好像太粗俗了
不好意思
不理會這件事情
好不好
OK嗎
所以你看這是專業
好不好
希望大家專業中帶種
与
專業中帶種
怎麼樣
這樣微笑
好 這樣學起來
好 第二個
我說台灣50
有沒有看到
昨天溢價1.1%
溢價1.1%
算有點多了
溢價什麼叫溢價
就是我價值100塊
你偏偏要101元去買它
就是你傻了
我們也傻了
不一定1%還可以接受
長期而言
短期而言可以接受
為什麼溢價那麼多
為什麼00981要溢價
你們看一下
台灣50要暫停板
ETF暫停板很難耶
代表是所有股票他暫停
好我們看元大台灣50的
首要全資股台積電
暫停嘛沒錯嘛
紅海有暫停嗎
壞掉了紅海
暗示我禮拜一紅海暫停是不是
等一下一下紅海有暫停嗎
紅海沒暫停
看起來喔
紅海沒有暫停
紅海沒暫停你看收完
你看收起來沒長對不對
好
然後前五大嘛
台大電影有暫停嗎
沒有暫停
全值股裡面
你看
他們要全部都暫停
成分股是暫停
我所有股票都暫停
你才能暫停
懂嗎
這是ETF嘛
你懂意思嗎
ETF是這樣子啊
我們滿分滿分滿分
我認見好了
ETF是平均嘛 全群眾嘛
我什麼叫
我最後平均
我問你件事就好
我問你件事好 認得不懂
好 我國英 數理
這四顆
我平均100分
對不對
Killian 懂嗎
我請問你我國中的時候
我國文 英文 數學 底話
每一顆都100分
平均100分
喔 等一下
我每 我平均100分
大概什麼意思
我99分 行不行
我三顆100
一顆99分有平均100分嗎
沒有
答案就出來了
這也是喔
國英
我國文英文數學裡的話
我跟別人講我平均100分
就算我三顆100分
一顆99分
也不是平均100分
你不要給我什麼四捨五入面
這一件事啊
可能99.99
99.99點多少
所以你就算三顆100分
你一顆99分
你還是不能平均100分
可是ETF就是平均啊
你懂不懂
平均的權重
平均的一個全眾人又有在斬跌幅
承擔他的斬跌幅
所以他只要全職國裡面沒有斬平
你就不應該
你跟我說你平均100分
你平均10%
我們的100分就是10%
因為斬幅最高就是10%
當然是斬幅
平均10%
所以台灣50會告訴你說平均10%
可是他沒有嘛
所以漲太多了
所以漲太多大家冷靜一下
漲太多了
這個某種方面漲太多
就有人賣股票
夜盤賣的比較兇
OK嗎
就這麼簡單
夜盤賣得比較兇
好不好
這為什麼夜盤賣得比較兇
很簡單嘛
你自己看一下嘛
就看一下
來
你看台灣股市
昨天的盤
週五的盤市漲快8%
夜盤跌20.46%
因為漲8%
2.46%還好
日本股市漲4%
有沒有看到
就只有2.1%
夜盤
所以平常行
好不好
只是溢價過多
大家稍微清醒
那可不可以買
當然可以買
可是這件事
禮拜五你看到國去展停
然後看到台積電展停
你看到環球進展停
你瞬間又覺得
早就應該相信者者
增加存者 想買
奇怪為什麼今天你看到
夜盤跌1000點
你又不想買了
變來變去
理論上不會破四萬點
好不好
因為AI進步很快
我跟你講
你們多跟他真人對話
你們用這個HGPT跟他對話
你會發現他反應越來越快
是不是
我們再跟他講個話好不好
我們看一下
我們臨時測試一下
哈囉
等一下 等他出來
他這樣最大問題就網路啦
跟電量
哈囉
嗨 來了 今天想聊什麼
我的粉絲 我現在
我是分析師 你知道嗎
分析師 了解
我看你跟我很不熟喔
我跟你講
我還在
還在理解是不是
好 你可以跟我多說說
沒有關係
因為現在你前面有
有100萬的粉絲在看我們節目
現在直播人數大概差不多有五六
七千人啦
所以我跟他們講說
現在投資是時候
他們有些人不相信
你不覺得你
關於是你進步就很快嗎
你聽說你最近一直在更換版本對不對
你最近一個禮拜要更換版本嗎
你查一下
了解
我可以幫你查
而且整體的服務的確一直有在更新啦
所以能力通常會慢慢提升
對不對 好 慢慢提升
你不覺得你以後可以
你這方面可以做真能克服嗎
因為我已經分不去你是真能假人了
你知道嗎
如果要做到即時高準確又合規的真能克服
還需要更嚴格的資料驗證跟風險控管
當然需要嘛
不然很容易出錯
對 還是需要
對 我覺得人還是很重要
但我也可以很快
很穩定的幫你做資料的整理
還有初步的分析
但價值判斷跟
不用不用
你真好玩
你管他還不夠聰明
一般的智能客服需要說
不好意思 我要買這台股票
沒有啊
我就說我要銷毀信用卡
對不對 我要剪卡
然後你們費用太高了
這卡費太高了
沒錯吧
對
是
就是
你說的沒錯
這類型
比較偏流程型的問題
其實真人處理
反而會更有效率
你反而覺得真的嗎
我是覺得
沒關係
我們拭目以待
好不好
你們是比較客氣的
OK嗎
這只是變
沒事
他們說我是OK
好不好
OK
不要這樣說
每個人都是重要的客戶
好 謝謝
你們覺得好假啊
我覺得這個很真耶
你知道為什麼他一直口急嗎
是因為我一直不讓他講話
你知道為什麼不讓他講話嗎
因為在這邊直播的時候
有時候lag我停一秒鐘感覺就很慢
你懂意思嗎
OK嗎 還是莉莉好
但真的好 但是比較好啊
是不是
你們要莉莉啊
喔 那莉莉 莉莉來了
莉莉來了 莉莉 講一下話
大家好 我是莉莉
妳名字就不是莉莉
金金啊 妳看多配合
就跟妳講啊
有家庭不一樣好不好
好啦
這公讀生 口即
這很不錯它不是口即啦
你們都去用
哎呀這不是口即好不好
喔
這次從不作假
不要再有人說我買那個作假啦
然後怎麼就跟你講
你說你沒有邏輯好不好
不要我那不喜歡太笨的人
我問真的
所以我作假的那個
嗯這個真的很笨耶
真的很笨
我這樣講就批評人家
我都說我願意給一億的
說永鋒金版新的
我永鋒金高層的
你找出證據來
我看
他看到一億現金的我要做假
他不檢舉我
對不對
我去講一件事
一億現金
我說給就給啊
因為這個網路時代還查不出來
要不要查而已
他們已經偷看到
怎麼會看不到我會不會買
我都是願意給他了
你把我這段影片給永鋒金的
給人家看都沒關係
永鋒金版新
會可以看到我資料的人
是不是
如果做假
我沒有買一億的
我先來一駕工
好不好
代表某方面你們真的瞧不起我
我就說我已經股市
已經是財富自由了
很多人不相信
好不好
笑死一個賺一千萬那麼多的蠻追
謝謝你啦
那個MKC
我覺得您比較好笑
因為你又嫉妒者
又不得不看我節目
哎呀幹嘛呢
這講話很討厭喔
好 來
而且說者作假的人
真的頭殼壞掉
所以那位記者要看我手機
我就給他們看啦
可是我說不能拍啦
我認識主管
你們真的
很多人都是菜鳥耶
我是去年
好像去年還是前年開始
我是因為主管機關要求說
這這太紅了啦
我們不要照人家困擾嘛
是不是
明明就不當分醫師
買台灣50
我們買ET不是合法的喔
啊
只是說對戰單不要好像覺得好像我賺很多
我想說好
那我就配合
去年前年
我都直接修對戰單
修我的帳號
沒有錯吧
不是去年
前年啦
都修我的帳號
好不好
OK
腰子肌膜也要看哲哲
很多人都看哲哲
其實很多投信人都看哲哲
新聞記者也有看我手機啦
好不好
好 那我跟大家講
所以這個結束啦
88%的人用越多啦
88%的也是蠻多的
12%的人我是跟你講真的啦
你要越用越
你吃早會越用越多的
你不用越越多的
我跟你講
要嘛太致富
要嘛就是
我不要去批評啦
我覺得會被取代
真的會被取代
相信我
OK啊
老師可以給乾粗社會的年輕人
多一些理財方向嗎
可以啊
我覺得如果是買ETF馬上就買
不要拖時間
因為時間是最棒的
因為你可能轉眼間
你根本不是
你知道為什麼最近我那麼好嗎
你知道為什麼最近那麼好嗎
因為除了我以外
基本上沒有人可以抓轉折這麼厲害
抓轉折這麼厲害
我在這邊買
然後直接暫停板
台股接近暫停板
台灣50台積電展停板
你們不是神的人
可是大家覺得我報當神
一般人抓不到這個展停板
一般人居然抓不到這個展停板
那是人命隨便買
你不要抓 抓不到
因為你在等時間
你可能等一等
馬上變4萬7 4萬8 5萬
基於這邏輯
所以年輕人
第二個
你想要人生衝一把
你想要穩定
你就買台灣50台積電
人生衝一把
看你是不是股神
那就買
年輕人
我反而建議你在你承受的範圍內
聽清楚 承受到的那樣
假設我100萬
我知道我可以數光光也沒關係
前提是我數光光也沒關係
你不像比如前面這三個
金晶 含一下
金晶 在
漂亮
不是 漂亮 不在
小韓 起了
這三個人
為什麼要認命
現在有家庭嗎
沒辦法啊
是不是不是 不是開玩笑這個你就不行因為不同的層次你懂不懂不同的層次好不同時間層次他們就不行不能這樣就不能把全部全部壓
因為他們要養家人
今天如果你二三十歲以下的
你一百萬你可以輸光光的
你以後對股票你很有信心
你覺得你有錢會成為股神
All in
然後甚至於你可以買一些權證
買一些期貨
這個我沒有很反對
可是前提是你可以接受輸光光
你知道
前提是你可以結束文官
OK
可是你要斷頭說要砍
就是你要變零
你不要變富啊
這個我不反對
前提是你要知道你要什麼
前提我講清楚
不要說哲哲又支持融資
因為你說不同年紀嘛
好不好
如果你就怕風險
那不要怪東怪西
又怪哲哲
那就絕對不要借錢
OK
等週一可能一千萬賠回去
當然不可能啦
你不要說
沒關係啦
這就好玩了
哲哲0150真的是大絕招
從沒有失守
對啊大家有沒有看過105
你沒有失守過好不好
太陽會不會針對
常常現在就被同意針對啊
我常常習慣啊
只能碩士班畢業
可不可以去你來跟這邊工作
這跟學歷沒有關係
這還滿機車的
這跟大家講
什麼事
40分
結束了結束了
不行這樣結束了
朋友叫我放棄台股換買港股
不行啦
港股現在沒有國外的資金的啦
現在買港股入股還不太行
買港股入股不太行
可是買大陸的房地產
我覺得如果你們喜歡對岸
大陸的房地產我就有機會
我覺得啦
我不是房地產專家
我覺得
因為跌無可跌啦
好不好
者者你再行房貸買0050嗎
這個
訴不說
善自是啦
這次不講
好不好
來
者者弄個執行貸失手失望跌
者者怎麼看沒料的財經網紅
我不看有沒有料
我看的是他們為什麼考分析師
你們就想要從人家裡面收錢嗎
你為什麼不考分析師
說自己很厲害
哪不考分析師
我們至少
我們高考分析師
至少業界要待個幾年
是不是
至少一兩年以上
但我不值了
你這樣子
我憑空而來說
我很厲害
你相信
被騙
你們被騙剛好而已
好不好
OK嗎
折的正額可以買嗎
不要問我
要問你自己
好不好
我就跟你講了
你如果人
只要是槓桿
都有可能
你能承受70%
80%的跌幅
那你就買正額
不要就不要
最好不要
我認為一般人都不適合
我跟你講
當你
我給你問他
好好好
對 應該這樣說好了
來 你聽我的邏輯
當你問郭哲隆
台灣五十正二可不可以買
基本上不可以買
天哪 這種事你還要問我
但沒根本不懂投資
你不懂投資你還要做什麼
忍命啊
不是聖大某一個教授嗎
他說哇
我
我是看稍微看了印象中
哇 他覺得他去投資股票
他不買250
沒錯啊 這觀念對
他講的觀念是對的
你要認命啊
你在問我要不要買真二的時候
基本上你已經不適合買真二了
基本上你連真二的產品
你都沒有在研究啊
對不對 這邏輯沒錯吧
基本上你是需要給人家建議的
不行啊 為什麼不行
買真二的時候
如果跌70%的時候
你還要人家給你建議
你根本就無所適從
懂嗎
當你問我郭哲隆
要不要買真二的時候
你絕對不適合
至少目前的你不適合
記得我這個邏輯
代表你根本還不知道投資是什麼
OK
來
那久了你就知道
好不好
政大財政系畢業可以去摸
學弟們好
那處理超不超啦
好不好
真的啦
永遠有時候整個比較超
可是至少我們敢超
因為我不敢說怎麼樣
至少這件事來求職工作是不是
不要這樣好不好
好啦
可是我跟你講
我們這就是平均業界薪水最高
好不好
就是大家去打聽
投信投顧
平均業界薪水最高
好不好
就去布拉格啦
布拉格也滿貴的
一個一個我看一下團費要快17萬吧
我頭好暈喔
一個人團費快17萬
都住五星級飯店
出去玩公司都住四季吧
那個文華東方吧
對都有住布拉格的
來
我們來看一下喔
最後跟大家講一些股票
所以股票
你看到礼拜五暫停
我問大家一件事
我再講一件事
你今天股票跌10%的
你真的來找我
今天我也沒有要做生意
公司希望
你看我現在講
反彈99專案
自己參考一下
礼拜五買不到的
礼拜一總算可以買
你還不買
那你不就是跟那些
礼拜四礼拜三的一樣嗎
你要幹什麼
買不到就用力
好不容易買到就用力買
珍惜
你們看清楚就看清楚
現在為什麼要買
因為現在一堆股票
你們冷靜一下吧
國具好不好
我真的
那我本來怕禮拜一國巨來暫停
那現在看起來禮拜一至少一開門不會暫停
一開門漫太高也不太好
國巨啦
你現在500啦
我說過了
你不要說漲到1200
你漲到800就好了
你國巨就算漲到800
你還有60%咧
你就算漲到800
就這樣哩
還有60%
你這邊要60%
輕輕鬆鬆
而且這邊60%是沒有壓力的
你相信我
到800元就漲很快
之後很難
所以你要到800元以後
之後很難的時候
你要做價差
一次300元的價差
你500元
假設你500元
假設你股票就這麼倒楣
套這500元
就這麼倒楣
你買在1200
假設你買1200
你每次300元
300元
都賺300元
是不是
你三次賺300元
不好意思
你就1400元了
到1400元了
沒錯吧 500加3次300不是就是
1400嗎
就解套了
解套了
知道嗎
1400元大於1220元
所以你這邊要做價差
你要找我
好不好
真的你有國際
你有一些被套的股票
你要找我
你有環球金
你有些股票
你要找我
好不好
這些公司擴產到時候
你要找我
我看很遠的
你知道嗎
我是講一件事
欣欣我70塊被人家罵
還被人家搞同業在那邊亂講話
一些奇怪
就某一個奇怪的媒體
是不是
常常被人家告的媒體
怂恿人家
怎麼樣
自救會
提告者則
只有全台灣唯一法院證明
證交所還查到證交所去
完全沒有異常的進出
全市場 全台灣所有的帳號
不只是我的帳號
沒有任何人頭帳戶的嫌疑
有什麼要配合主力
孝使人從股價外
從70塊漲到1000多
這是市場的力量
不是主力的力量而已
是不是 不是主力的力量
從70元漲到1000多塊
問你啊 就算現在星星
從1100跌到787
還是漲了十倍 漲到十倍
我告訴你 那時候我就知道
ABU載板會很缺貨
你現在看到有什麼用
懂我意思嗎
細菌源到時候會很缺
相信我
有很多
因為AI的體制下
AI的投資下面
有雖然多超級循環
不要 我看
不論是記憶體
不論是被動人權
籌碼都亂了
創新高會很辛苦
你記得計畫
好不好
太陽又有電跟盛高漲17%
春田製作所
太陽用電跟盛高是細晶圓的
就日本的細晶圓領導產商
長17%
長得比
春田製作所13%還多
多4%
代表是
細晶圓反逃的力道
日本的細晶圓反逃的力道
大於
被動元件
那為什麼不買
我也不懂中美金為什麼那天殺那麼低
好不好
OK嗎
這樣跟大家講有沒有聽到
所以你想想看你要展分一次
不要像韓國賞戶一樣
你看賞戶賞戶真的悲哀
你看悲哀很可惜被政府搞
韓國股市單日串三個基督
我看漲幅很誇張
15-17%以上
韓
最後
韓國賞戶信心崩潰
賣超10.5兆元
你拜五還在賣
賣啦
17.9%是怎麼多
賞物賣10.5兆
等於賞物賣了2000億 安扯
賞物賣2000多億
當天賣了2000多億是不是
31日漲幅賞物賣超
外資賣超 軍器算紀錄
其實你們一開始都
問題是如果一開始都沒有農資
你看到韓國大漲
你會有壓力嗎
所以你現在平產行好不好
所以差不多要結束了
差不多整個要結束了
還有什麼東西
沒有問題好不好
沒有問題反正久久
當然要跟大家講
所以這純粹是一些東西
邏輯告訴你
為什麼
斬多拉火而已
禮拜五你想買
禮拜六你就不想買
你不覺得很傻嗎
用週年期的感覺跟大家講好不好
來啦
這個跟大家講
然後美國財報
現金流為付
本來是票房毒藥
現在現金流為付不重要
這代表假議題
大家也知道AI是趨勢嘛
好不好
韓國在跌下去的時候
還會救世 五大救世
還會禁止放空啊
叫開始庫殘古實施啊
對不對
融資基增100億
散戶回來的不妙
我覺得散戶回來還比較妙
韓國比較可憐
記得我最後講這一話
來 我們來看一下
你去看一下
這不只一次
連續三年都在跌
怎麼樣
跌超過五六千點的時候
我反彈
後來彈兩萬兩千點
我買了這邊多漂亮
還有在這邊
2024年買在最低點
他們買
你看他們買在最低點的時候
反彈都會修正一下
修正整理一天
我們看一下喔
2024年是這樣喔
這又長又黑的長域可以辦
是不是修正整理
這個是像禮拜三嘛
禮拜四殺下去嘛
禮拜四反彈
當然有一處殺下去
都會整理一下
禮拜五直接噴出去
噴出去完以後
欸 是不是禮拜五
有點像禮拜五喔
禮拜三
你們看一下
最後給你結論
你看一下
看一下
這個台灣股市
我們最後看
幾分呢
哇 時間太精彩了
可是我最後要講一下
跌破四萬點在這邊對不對
對不對
沒錯吧
我們放大放大
跌破四萬點在這邊
你看到禮拜一
還會再一次測破底
測完破底以後
直接長黑K
大展展停板
隔天禮拜一可能會收黑
可是收完黑以後
會再次反彈
來
看一下結論
去年前年
我台灣股市都買在
最低點這邊很漂亮
去年有沒有看到
關稅有沒有看到
跌停板
反彈過後怎麼樣
隔天再一次徹底有沒有看到
然後直接送OK
送OK又怎麼樣
有再一次
他們前波低點
哇他這個還隔了一個禮拜算多
結果從此又一路漲
所以我就認為台灣的整理時間
不到一個禮拜
結果現在就會開始慢慢一路漲
慢慢一路漲
好這是去年
前年
反彈有沒有看到
反彈過後有沒有看到
然後隔天再一次徹底
有沒有看到
一直徹底跟現在很像
就像禮拜五一樣
禮拜三破底破四萬
禮拜四再徹底
禮拜五反彈
有沒有到
禮拜反彈以後
有沒有
有點像禮拜一
收黑K
有沒有到
禮拜一有沒有到
禮拜一跌
但是有下引線
有沒有到
結果禮拜二再噴出去
噴噴噴噴噴
他們都會再一次反覆徹底
可是反覆徹底的時間
不會很長
所以你禮拜一不買
你會後悔一輩子啦
好不好
結束了結束了
反彈就是專案
沒想到今天還可以拉迪賽拉那麼久
好不好
哲子今天比較沒有
那個
雙方賣傻
會比較不好笑
不要說雙方賣傻
比較娛樂大家
財慾於親啊
反正就有專案趕快來
好不好
這是跟大家自己看要不要
反正問的人很多
不論對我或錯
哲子一切一切一切一切一切
今天週末加班
你愛我嗎
我愛你們
我來支持你們
真的就像簡直講的
不要錯過
再愛哲子最後一次機會
我知道你會愛我一輩子
可是前提是你要加入韓列
或者要相信我
不論對我或錯
我哲哲一切一切用到前面
歡迎來敲請0806808
或叫我來私訊我
哲哲愛大家
也希望大家
愛哲哲趕快來加入馬行業
預祝各位能夠賺大錢
謝謝各位 掰掰
努力判斷、省慎評估並自負投資風險